good morning everybody and welcome to
the design Futures Forum
2023 this city is where we spend almost
60 years prototyping that future using
design Innovation to overcome our
challenges and look for new ways of
doing
things I don't know what's green means I
don't know what sustainable means I just
do whatever I can I like to do without
wasting material how might design
designers here support the
redistribution of knowledge of ideas of
resources so that we all might have
enough if we think of design as a lens
through which we can perceive complex
problems like the climate crisis then
what is important to protect is the way
of
seeing when we sell the energy from this
roof it can actually Finance 100% of the
cost of the house and so to be
sustainable we actually meet all three
to design with our head heart and hands
I think the moral of the story is that
design and Tech is really a movement for
us it's about building a culture of
[Music]
experimentation so we're talking about
how
organizations Ministries building bodies
can leverage digital twins the physical
world to really accelerate the entire
build cycle we need to empower creators
to design immersive experiences that
create positive change for people and
planet and it's about designers creating
the right nudges at the right time
treatments are created but care is
essential to The Human Experience what
is your joyful truth what is Your Love
Letter to the world whether you're a
designer or a clinician you're a human
being so how can can you the design
community help to elevate suffering how
can we design for kindness can we
actually R design the way our services
are according to how a citizen looks at
it from their life moment designers have
The Bravery to say there is another way
in fact there are infinite ways of
achieving our desired outcomes Singapore
without design is a Singapore without
imagination and we need imagination to
inspire and build that future together I
look forward to working with all of you
continue to take design and the future
of Singapore to greater and greater
Heights